they've been recently formed in GCC and
a levels in the UK and this is a matter
of concern for lots of students
considering applying to Oxford now the
main thing to remember is our
consideration and GCC's is not going to
change we've always looked highly at
jesus' and we do take them into care for
consideration when looking at students
applications from our point of view what
we're looking for is a strong
performance across the board but
particularly sort of getting the high
numbers in the new GCC system so that's
nines eights and sevens across GCC's
from a range of subjects that are going
to help in your later application so if
you studying reduces ease at the moment
or about to keep working hard key thing
is to get to get a strong rest as
possible now if you've already studied
your GCC's and you're worried about how
you might performed or how the
university looks at your grades the
important thing to remember is that we
look at the information we put it
against your school's performance local
performance and national performance to
give to come out with some contextual
data about you so that means that we
don't like to say a candidate from
Oxford should have this amount of juice
disease or to this standard because
different people's juicy grades are
going to differ massively across the
board when it comes to a levels you
might be concerned about the reform that
means that changes from splitting at AAS
at the end of the first term coming out
with a set of grades through to the
second year and coming out with another
set of grades it's going to affect your
application now the way we used to use
AAS is essentially gave us a little bit
more information about how you're doing
on a course teachers predictions in this
way were very crucial in the way that we
look at how a candidate is predicted to
perform at a level but the lack of the a
s grades doesn't really change how we as
a university admit students so please
don't worry if suddenly your course is
lost it's a yes aspect we all look at it
in exactly the same way as lots of
courses where AES is just don't exist
thank you so much to Dan for agreeing to
be interviewed if you'd like to check
out more videos about Oxford and
Cambridge admissions then check out the
playlist that's on the screen now and
linked in the description below
also take a look at the social media
links in the description for Sint
Peter's College which is mile college
there are links to Facebook Twitter
snapchat and Instagram where you can see
a snapshot of student life at an Oxford
College